[Musique]
une cinquantaine de jeunes conseillers
départementaux de l'est et du nord se
sont retrouvés ce mercredi 3 mai à bras
panon dans la salle polyvalente pour une
première approche de l'europe et du
monde agricole
un partenariat entre le département les
professionnels du secteur et le centre
régional d'information jeunesse
on est là pour faire de l'éducation au
choix sur les métiers david shore et
parler
des ados t
qu'ils peuvent
bénéficier à la réunion notamment le
feader qui bénéficie aux agriculteurs et
à l'espace aux espaces que vous dans
différents ateliers pédagogiques qui se
décline en fait grâce à
différents visuels où les jeunes pousses
justement participer activement et être
acteurs de leur apprentissage au travers
de la découverte du monde
agricole les jeunes ont ainsi pu
découvrir toute une palette de
professions liées au travail des champs
et à l'élevage des animaux mais aussi
comprendre l'implication de l'europe
dans le développement des structures
agricoles de notre département
aujourd'hui j'ai pu apprendre beaucoup
de choses parce que j'ai pas de famille
qui fait de l'agriculture qui est
invaincu et du coup il ya beaucoup de
choses que je ne connaissais pas donc
des métiers et des fonctions
donc j'en tue c'est pu apprendre
beaucoup de choses et ça m'a permis de
d'élargir les connaissances sur
l'agriculture s'est vu la cedeao l aféas
d'air et que qu'est ce que ça voulait
dire de faire partie de l'union
européenne ce que ça allait donner comme
avantage et comme on l'avait des aides
nous à la réunion et même partout dans
l'union européenne
la délégation s'est ensuite rendue dans
l'exploitation des devins payette à
saint benoît un moment des changes qui a
permis aux jeunes de se rendre compte
des investissements liés à l'europe par
l'intermédiaire des fonds feader
en fait moi moi j'ai baissé de 50 % des
aides en fait même sur factures
acquittées qui m'a permis en fait
d'alléger en fait des charges que qu'ils
ont pu aloha dia sur l'exploitation les
conseillers départementaux jeunes de
l'ouest et du sud se retrouveront le 24
mai prochain pour à leur tour partir à
la découverte des agriculteurs et de
l'europe
[Musique]